[Music]
you think you know how the world works
you think that this material universe is
all there is but what if I told you the
reality you know is one of many this
doesn't make any sense not everything
has to dr. strange
throwing the mystic Artes we harness
energy and shape reality the Avengers
protect the world from physical dangers
we safeguarded against poor mystical
sweats
who died protecting this worth mr.
doctor
mr. doctor it's strange maybe cool as a
judge
hey youtubers is Charlie new Doctor
Strange footage and a whole bunch of
people got to visit the set so we
learned a whole bunch about the movie
and what's going on with this in the
Marvel Universe so this is gonna be a
breakdown really the big thing in this
footage is the mass Mikkelsen at the end
like that funny end tag in him with the
cloak of levitation in a better look at
their magical battles so it's more of a
martial arts magic movie so I know that
makes you think of Iron Fist so this
will have a lot of parity with what's
going on in Iron Fist even though that's
much more practical martial arts it just
gives in to the way magic is expressed
physically in the Marvel Universe
instead of being like Emperor Palpatine
from Star Wars
just shooting bolts of lightning at Luke
Skywalker so Scott Derrickson the
director said that was like a big thing
for them visually when they were talking
about how is this gonna work because
magic is their primary source of power
so like how are they gonna fight each
other what's it gonna look like so they
all felt like there had been too much
reliance on shooting beams of light at
each other they even do it during the
Avengers movies so as a way to make this
look way cooler and you know it's not
completely recycle everything that
they've done before they turned it into
more of a martial arts movie so that
heavily influenced the way they weave
magic the weight like the way they
manifest magical spells the way they
fight each other and then you see the
non attack magic throughout the trailer
as they open portals they said there's
about four big action set pieces in one
of the ones that critics got to see
early was kind of from early on and dr.
Strange's training where the ancient one
teleports him to Mount Everest in his
part of this lesson forces him to open
his own portal to return before he dies
from frostbite Kevin Feige also talked a
lot about the role of science because
this is a magic movie so the Marvel
Universe thus far has been very
technology-based has been dominated by
Iron Man and his ethos of building
cooler toys building ways of harnessing
energy so the Doctor Strange movie deals
with that in a really interesting way
but there were like big sequences early
on that they cut out of the movie like
there was a sequence that took place at
the super collider at cern but that
ended up getting cut out but you know
the way they deal with it in the thor
movies and in saying that well before
people understood how all this work they
thought it was magic so this will be
actual magic but there will be a
scientific element to it parallel
dimensions multiverse Kevin Feige one of
the most exciting things we've been
talking about multiverse and Doctor
Strange Kevin Feige confirmed all that
stuff so you can see like maths
Nicholson's character has seen the truth
like he has been exposed to something of
awesome power and wants to make it a
reality
so he's collapsing all the dimensions
into our dimension would you basically
destroy everything but that's one of the
reasons why like his eyes look kind of
crazy like they're called zealots like
that's the name of their group in this
other movie they've been to the other
plate like obviously there are multiple
other dimensions but there are certain
ones like the Dark Dimension
dormammu's dimension that are specific
to the Doctor Strange universe these
people have seen that they've been
tainted by the truth so to speak if you
guys have watched Full Metal Alchemist
like you see the truth and you're
scarred by it that's kind of the vibe
that I'm getting from them so let me
know what you guys think about the idea
of a martial arts magic movie and even
though we do know that Doctor Strange is
going to be an infinity war the next big
point of crossover seems like it's going
to be the Thor movie although the
director of that movies been kind of
funny when people ask him questions like
how come Thor is looking at dr.
Strange's Street address on that little
card there and he's like I don't I don't
know what you're talking about it could
be nothing just kind of like winking you
know like okay there's something going
on here but obviously we can't reveal
everything right now but I just feel
like there's so much big new stuff
they're introducing and Doctor Strange
that yeah we all see little tags for
this in the other movies between now and
infinity war like he won't go from zero
to Dormammu overnight but it's gonna be
so crazy and it's gonna be so awesome
I'm just so ready for the Marvel
Universe to get really weird now it's
like you've seen enough of the regular
earth-based movies we also learned who
Rachel McAdams is playing she's playing
Christine Palmer who is night nurse in
the Doctor Strange comics now I know
there's a lot of confusion because
Rosario Dawson's Claire temple is kind
of like the functional night nurse of
the Marvel Universe like the
street-level person who treats
vigilantes they can't go to the hospital
for fear of being identified
so no version of Claire temple
the comics has ever been called night
nurse there have been three different
versions of the night nurse the official
night nurse character Christine Palmer
is the most recent one and I think part
of the reason Marvel has not used the
name in the MCU yet is just to avoid
creating more confusion so she's not
going to be called night nurse in the
Doctor Strange movie in Claire temple is
not going to be called night nurse in
the daredevil Netflix universe
they'll just be called their names like
she'll be called Claire she'll be called
Christine and that'll be that but I
think we can consider a Claire temple
the actual night nurse even though
technically Christine Palmer is the only
comic book accurate version of night
nurse but she's a relatively small
character in the Doctor Strange movie
itself a lot of people thought that she
might have been playing clea
who's kind of like this extra
dimensional love interest for dr.
strange who actually just appeared in
the latest Doctor Strange comic book if
you've been reading Doctor Strange
comics they just had the annual Kalia
comes back so you get an idea for who
her character is if you've never read
about her before that as far as we know
CLIA is not in the Doctor Strange movie
Rachel McAdams is playing Christine
Palmer aka
one of the night nurses so hopefully
that clears that up just a little bit
but if you guys didn't know they are
airing 15 minutes of the movie like a 15
minute preview at special IMAX theaters
around the country so I don't know if
they're doing this internationally but
it's an IMAX the IMAX is the one that's
putting this on it's on the 10th of
October so if you go to IMAX's website
you might be able to find tickets I
think it's sold out and now like those
are the kind of things that sell out
right away because it's only on one day
and it's like one specific theater for
each city so it's kind of crazy but
don't worry and just to tie this to
Ghost Rider I'm getting ready to make an
agents of shield video next I'll make my
Ghost Rider episode 2 video but they did
something during agent Carter season 2
with dark energy like the Dark Dimension
so it seems like they're carrying that
idea like that the MacGuffin of that
forward with Ghost Rider people trying
to manipulate energy extra dimensional
energy and it doing really crazy things
to them and then Doctor Strange is like
the idealized version of that storyline
so it's all connected
at least on a story level so that agents
of shield ghostrider video will post in
a little while be sure to subscribe to
get it it was a big reveal for the
director of shortly they finally
revealed who the new director of shield
is is a super deep cut from the Captain
America comics and then those new flash
season 3 there's a new like really big
arrow season 5 trailer so that might not
post til Thursday
agents of shield next then the DC stuff
so DC stuff might not post all Thursday
just because there's so much stuff that
just dropped this morning well you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
for the final big Luke Cage trailer all
dropping this Friday and you can click
here for my Thor funny moments super cut
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight